so a very good morning and thank you for
coming for my talk though shall judge
but with fairness methods to ensure and
unbiased model
sriraj I am a data scientist at
scientist.ai
so let's move on to the talk so before I
start with my talk I will just like to
quote a phrase from the book To Kill a
Mockingbird
so people generally see what they look
for and hear what they listen for so
human beings are like in general human
beings generally make judgments but we
as human beings must mention that the
judgments that we make are fair likewise
our ml models or ml algorithms also make
judgments and we have to make sure that
the judgments that our ml model makes
are fair thus it brings us to our topic
though shall judge but with fairness
methods to ensure an unbiased model
so I'll just give you an agenda of
today's talk first we'll be starting
with the introduction then we'll be
moving on to what bias and ml models
means and then we'll be seeing what
model fairness is then we'll be moving
on to model sinus mitigation in three
main stages of the ml models pipeline
then we'll be seeing some useful
fairness evaluation matrices followed by
python python code to Gorge the fairness
of a model trained on a law school data
set full by conclusion so let's open to
the introduction so let me throw the
throw throw some lights on the growing
importance of machine learning in
artificial intelligence in today's
scenario so big data and machine
learning are pervasive and have a very
Rising influence on the current Society
so our world is getting automated day by
day so most of the daily tasks that we
do are influenced in one way or the
other by some AI or some machine
learning algorithm so let's take this
jobs training platforms even jobs
training Platforms in the preliminary
stages use AI or ml so yeah in every
day-to-day task we can find some ml
algorithm and in in today's scenario
nowadays even ml algorithms are getting
used in decision making scenarios Let It
Be of an individual or let it be of an
organization or a business so there is a
very stressing need or very pressing
need to make sure that our ml algorithms
or our machine learning models are fair
and ethical
so uh before we move into machine
learning models fan is let me uh like
introduce you to the term bias and ml
models
so yeah bias is kind of a vague word so
let me try to Define it to you so we say
that a bias has occurred when rml
algorithm displays in a inaccurate or
inappropriate results due to flawed ml
assumptions so we all know that our
machine learning model is built upon a
number of ml assumptions so when these
assumptions are flawed or are like
actually faulty this will lead to our ml
model making predictions that are
actually wrong or inaccurate and desired
predictions
so a bias can exist in any any shape or
any form and it can be introduced in any
stage of an ml models pipeline so let me
try to brief you the ml model pipeline
so it starts with business understanding
then we collect the data then we label
the data we train the model we deploy
the model and then we evaluate the model
so a bias can be introduced in any of
these stages let it be the business
understanding stage or the data
collecting stage or maybe the last stage
model evaluation stage a bias can get
introduced in any of these stages
so uh let me try to Define bias bias is
a phenomenon when a model or ml model
consistently make predictions that are
skewed due to faulty premises or maybe
faulty ml assumptions societos and as I
already mentioned that the ml algorithms
are even getting used in the
decision-making sector so these buyers
can lead to like significant losses or
significant mistakes too so we need to
make sure that our ml model is free of
buyers so let me give you a brief
example regarding of bias so let's take
this example of compass compass is
Correctional offender management
profiling for alternate sanctions so
let's forget the full form let's take it
as Compass so Compass is an ml algorithm
that was used in the state codes in the
United States to predict if a person is
reoffending or not and it has been seen
that uh the African Americans had a
higher chance to be predicted as
reoffending than they actually did and
the white Americans had a lesser chance
to be predicted as reoffending so this
is like a very this is a decision making
scenario and we don't want such kind of
bias in such a like State Court scenario
so the bias that needs to be removed so
that is why this topic becomes relevant
so let me try to like brief you like
what are the types of biases that can
exist the first one is bias and data so
we can actually divide bias and data
broadly into three the first one is
historical bias historical bias is the
bias that is inherent in the data or
that is seeped in through the data even
if the data or even if we collect data
from perfectly sampling environments
there might be some bias that is
actually inherent in the data or that is
actually seeped into the data even if we
like make sure that everything is right
and this is known as historical bias
the second one is representative bias
representative bias occurs from the
scenario or the population from which
we're actually Gathering the data so
maybe the population from which we're
collecting the data is not representing
all the population that is desired so
let me give you an example that is the
data collected from smartphones so the
data collected from smartphones are
underrepresentative of the data of
people with lower income other people
who cannot afford smartphones so their
data is absent in the early data
collected from smartphones right so
their data is not getting represented
and this is representative bias
the third one is measurement bias
measurement bias occurs from the noise
in the environment from which we are
collecting the data so maybe the labels
are getting labeled incorrectly or maybe
we are getting like wrong feature values
so due to the noise in the environment
we may get like wrong values so this
leads to measurement bias so measurement
bias historical bias and representative
buyers together constitute bias and data
now moving on to bias and modeling
so bias and modeling can be actually
categorized into two the first one being
evaluation bias so evaluation bias
occurs in the model iteration or the
model training phase
so for ML so for every ml algorithm that
we use so we have set certain benchmarks
to qualify like this model is good so if
it crosses certain benchmarks okay we
say that okay this model is good if it's
not matching certain Benchmark we say
okay this is underperforming so these
benchmarks be actually tend to
generalize these benchmarks but these
benchmarks may not be applicable for
each and every case so there might be
scenarios where these Benchmark may not
be applicable for this particular
scenario and this leads to evaluation
bias and the second one is aggregation
bias aggregation bias occurs when
different populations are combined
inappropriately to train our model okay
I'll try to explain that with an example
from the healthcare sector so let's take
the example of a model used to predict
the level of like predict whether a
person is diabetic or not from the
levels of hba1c so which means it has
been seen that the levels of hba1c
differ across various ethnicities that
is the level of hpa1c is different
across different ethnic groups so we
can't get like a generalized model to
predict whether a person is diabetic or
not across all these ethnicities and
this leads to aggregation bias so
aggregation bias and evaluation bias
totally constitute bias in modeling
now moving on to the third type of bias
bias and human review so this happens
when a human reviewer a human person
actually overrides the predictions that
are made by the ml model and he induces
his bias into like the ml model and that
causes bias in human review
now moving on to the umbrella term of
model fairness so okay model fences
another vague term which I'll try to
Define it for you so it can be broadly
defined as the absence of prejudice or
preference for a particular individual
or a particular subgroup or a particular
group or community
so it can be understood as designing or
creating algorithms that are actually
free of bias free of outside bias and
gives us accurate and desired
predictions or desired results so this
is how we can Define model fairness on a
broader scale
now moving on to model fairness
mitigation in three stages of our ml
models pipeline the first stage being
data mining so in this stage where we
collect the data the first thing that we
need to do is identify our protected
attributes so our particularly reviews
in our case may be like religion it can
be race it can be ethnicity or it can be
gender there can be like a number of
particular attributes so first step
should be to identify we should know our
data set so we should be able to
identify the predicted attributes and we
need to measure the data distributions
of this protected attribute
and we need to ensure that every
subgroup inside a protected attribute is
having a good representation or enough
representation or data we need to ensure
that no subgroup is being
underrepresented a no subgroup is being
overrepresented in order to prevent like
the representative bias that already I
mentioned so in some cases we'll get
data sets where like a subgroup is like
like we don't have enough data for a
subgroup in these cases we may resort to
techniques like over sampling or we may
use like some techniques to create
synthetic data set and our whole motive
should be to have a very balanced data
set that is like a really key point to
avoid bias I mean eliminate bias
now moving on to the model training
phase
in the model training phase we need to
like actually identify the metrics that
we are going to use to evaluate our
model's fairness and bias and either use
them while while training the model as
we go on I'll be showing you like a few
materials that can be used there are
like a number of matrices that you can
use but I'll be pointing you out like a
very few matrices when I go on but yeah
you'll get more clarity on this as we go
forward
so the last phase that is the post
processing and deployment phase in this
phase we need to compute the fairness
matrices on the test data set and also
it's like really essential to know the
distribution of data in our test data
set so we already have already
identified our protected attributes or
sensitive attributes so we need to get
the distribution of data for our test
data set for that particular product
attribute we need to see whether okay
this particular subgroup is
underrepresented or over represented in
our test data set and in second and
another essential thing is to see the
performance metrics of this protected
attribute so we need we can use like
accuracy or Precision or recall like
whatever needed so we need to see
whether these performance matrices are
actually performing well for every
subgroup inside a protected attribute
and then there are like a lot of tools
open source tools that are available
which will help us to like detect bias
and eliminate bias so I'll be mentioning
a few tools as we go on through so you
may use them to like identify and
mitigate your bias too and another key
essential point is to evaluate and keep
track of your production's fairness
metrics so that is also really essential
now as I mentioned these are like some
of the tools for early which you can use
to detect and mitigate your machine
learning models fairness the first one
is like these are all open source tools
so first one is Microsoft fell on so
Microsoft so as we go on I'll also be
showing like a demo with a law school
data set to go how to compute Finance
matrices I'll be using the first one
that is Microsoft fell on but but IBM's
AI fan is 360 is like equally good
Google there is Google's what-if tool
and there is equitas all of these you
can use in order to calculate or compute
like the bias and they also have
techniques to mitigate them
now moving on to some useful fairness
evaluation matrices
the first one is error rate so these are
actually uh like technical terms as that
you can actually use to compute your
model standards first one is error rate
error rate is the degree of prediction
error in your data set so for all these
famous evaluation matrices that I'm
going to say you can actually set a
threshold there are actually a set of
accepted values for the same for error
rate like the accepted value is 0.1 you
can actually these are kind of hyper
parameters that you can tune according
to your use case or according to your
data set but they are generalized
accepted value for error rate is 0.1 so
you can see it you can say that if the
ml models like the error rates that
you're getting is greater than 0.1 it's
kind of alarming and then if it's like
below 0.1 okay you're good to go with
error rate so you can Define your
Finance metrics and uh like the
threshold for the same
the second one is equalized odds
equalized odds ensures that the accuracy
is high for each and every subgroup
inside your protected attribute and it
ensures that your model is not just
favoring the majority subgroup but also
the minority subgroup and equalizer
helps us to punish the model if it only
favors the majority group and if the
accuracy is only great for the majority
group maybe your overall model's
accuracy might be like 94 percent or 95
percentage but maybe for a potent a
particular subgroup or a certain
subgroup it's the accuracy is really low
so equalized odds helps us to identify
that
the next one is demographic parity
demographic parity says that a model is
fair if the if the number of positive
predictions of this particular subgroup
matches its group membership percentages
so I already told these sort of like
technical terms like technical matrices
bear with me on that
and now this next one is overall
selection rate overall selection rate is
the number of elements that are selected
or the number of candidates that are
selected so the total number of
candidates under consideration
and the last one is the area under the
arrow sticker so Roc curve is like a
graph that represents the performance
metrics of a classification model in all
possible scenarios so area under the rot
also gives us a good like understanding
on how fair our model is performing
now moving on to the python code to
gauge the fairness of your ml model so I
have used a law school data set and a
classification model so the data set had
20 427 rows the protected attribute that
I used is race there were a is ranging
from one to eight one two three four
five seven eight the target variable
that I used was bar passed or not it's
like a binary variable zero or one
now moving on to the model that I've
used I've used a simple decision tree
classifier I just divided the data set
into test and train I just used a simple
dysentery classifier to make the
predictions
now moving on to the portion of our
interest that is using Fair learn to
Gorge the fairness matrices so basically
felon is an open power open source like
package and it has like I already
mentioned the matrices like overall
selection date demographic parity
equalized thoughts error rate Etc so far
along has like inbuilt libraries you
just need to import Fallon call the
function whichever you need past the
parameters so that's all that you need
to do and it'll do everything for you
your job is done and now as I told it's
very important to compute the
performance matrices too and we need to
analyze how it's pure like your model is
performing for each and every subgroup
inside your practical attribute Salon
also allows us to do the same so failure
has something called metric frame so in
metric frame we just need to specify
like which all uh accuracy like which
all uh performance materials that we
need to use I have used these like
accuracy precision FBR fnr through
positive rate through negative rate
selection rate mean prediction and count
there are a number of like medicines
more you can use any of them so uh just
call this import metric frame pass which
all performance matrices that you need
just call the function and it will give
you like the results
now moving on to some visualization
about the data set and the results so
this is the data set that I've used and
this is the distribution of the
protected attribute Trace you can see
Rays from one to eight and you can see
that our data set is not very balanced
so you can see that 4 is having like a
very the red one is having a very high
population well three and six are having
a relatively lower population
and now this is how Fairlawn gives you
the result for fairness mattresses so
like you'll get values like these you
can set thresholds like there are
accepted values you can also set
thresholds according to your need you
can tune them but the assay told for
error 8 like say if the threshold is 0.1
so here the error rate is 0.08 it is
below 0.1 okay your modest model is
performing fair so like likewise for all
these like overall selection really
demographic parity ratio parity
reference equalizer difference
everything you can set thresholds and
check if your model is performing Fair
now analyzing the performance matrices
for each and every class of this
protected attribute so you can see that
like they're all bar charts and they're
having like eight bars representing each
one of the Rays from one to eight let's
just consider the first graph first blue
graph for accuracy so you can see that
for my particular this model the
accuracy every for every single race
it's below zero like it's above 0.5 so
it's having pretty good accuracy for
each and every race in my case but it
might not be the case in your case maybe
in your case the accuracy might be low
for a particular like race you'll be
able to identify from this so yeah like
if you go to the last graph that is
Count you can see that four is having
like a very big bar uh whereas like
three and six are having relatively
lower so in this case what I could infer
is that 3 and 6 is like having lower
population I need to create more
synthetic data or more or like I could
do over sampling to create a more
uniform data set so likewise you can
infer from all these graphs so like what
you can do for your particular use case
now moving on to conclusion so let's sum
up what if uh like learn so we have seen
what biases and what different types of
biases are and then we have seen model
fairness and then we have seen model
Finance mitigation in like different
different stages in your ml models
pipeline we have also seen like the
various tools that can be used in
various materials that can be used to
gorge in ml models fairness we also saw
a small demo on how to use Microsoft
felon to gauge the fairness of your ml
model let me conclude my talk by quoting
a phrase said by Professor HP Jagdish
from University of Michigan
it is up to us as responsible data
scientists to make sure that we're using
the power of technology to do the right
thing thank you
[Applause]
until we wait for some extra questions
on slido I want to thank you for your
great talk thank you
let's come to the first question I saw
is VOC culture this solution to fairness
in ml uh can I see the question is Vogue
culture the solution to fairness in ml
like when when we are all when all
people are ethic unbiased is ml also
unbiased no we can't say that so like
according to me like as far as I know we
can't say that there's no situation like
which is free of bias like it's kindly
it's like something ideal right there's
we can't say that this situation or this
scenario is completely free of bias or
completely ethical so there's nothing
like as of now it's something ideal and
it's something hypothetical we can't see
we can't say that there's something like
completely ideal so according to me in
every situation
can exist it can be induced in any part
of the pipeline so even if like everyone
wakes up or something but we need to
ensure like this needs to be ensured in
the pipeline
how to identify protected groups if they
are not available in the data due to
privacy reasons
uh okay so actually
I didn't get the question how to
identify protected groups if they are
not available in the data due to privacy
reasons okay so there is there is
nothing like straightforward protected
groups or something uh so there are like
I hope this answers the question so
there are like some generalized
protected attributes such as race gender
religion and even if like these are just
like some question that can come to your
mind is we can just remove it right but
no like this can be implicitly also
implied like ins through some zip codes
or something this can be implicitly uh
like imply so I think how you can
identify them is that like there are
like certain straightforward protected
groups that are available that is race
religion that you can find a setup in
like when you Google it you can find
like a set of productive attributes that
you can get and for privacy Reasons I'm
not understanding like if the data is
there you can if you can identify what
are the column names or what are the
columns under consideration you will be
able to identify the product creatives
it's very straightforward
how do you know that the fairness
metrics are not biased by themselves
that is so pretty like that's a tricky
question
I
I I'm afraid I'll be able to answer that
but yeah like
you we're not just using one metric
right so we are using a combination of
fairness matrices combination of
performance matrices combination of data
distribution like everything when I was
just looking into one particular thing
since it's a combination of many things
like even if one of the one of them is
biased it's okay we can get gorgeous
from the others it's we are not just
concentrating on one thing so yeah
a model predicting credit credibility
predicts men are more credible oh wait
are more credible than females simply
because of the gender pay Gap how to
trade off accuracy and fairness
a model predicting credit credibility
predicts men are more credible than
females simply because of the K the paid
gender pay Gap how to trade off accuracy
for fairness
okay so yeah this this like in this case
I'll just refresh a question so the
question comes in like uh you know so
some of the some of the question so we
have this gender as a feature in this
particular data set that he has
mentioned and for gender like yeah uh
earlier there's a pay gap between men
and women so as mentioned here in the
question so how to like uh so it's
something historical right there's it
was something that happened in the
history it's kind of historical bias
that the question the person is
mentioning in the question and he's
asking how to trade off accuracy to
prediction like to fairness there's
nothing like to trade of accuracy for
fairness the thing that we need to do is
find a balance between both like we need
to find out uh like um a proper balance
between accuracy and fairness and as we
know In fairness also we're looking into
the accuracy so it's kind of it comes in
to that also so there's nothing that you
need to trade off your accuracy for
fairness it's better to find like a
balance between both and yeah ensuring a
balanced data set I think won't
compromise on your accuracy and even if
like uh like we made the main thing I
would suggest is to find a proper
balance between like your fairness and
accuracy you don't need to like give off
your accuracy just go after go behind
fairness like you can actually find a
balance between both that is the ideal
scenario
Patrick is asking how can I make sure
that I don't miss any protected
attributes or groups
that's a good question so
it's
a finding particular attributes is kind
of a it's it's straightforward but then
it can become tricky in some cases but
the main thing that you can like do is
that understand your data set so that's
the first thing that we can do
understand your data set understand the
columns under consideration and as I
have mentioned there are a lot of like
typical bias like for data bias modeling
bias or biasing human review see your
data set see whether which see which
bias applies for you like see the scope
of each and every bias so let it be like
historical bias or gender so when you
like go into each and every bias you can
see okay this particular attribute can
like come under this bias this
particular attribute can cause this bias
so go through like this different types
of bias identify scenarios like
understand a data set identify scenarios
where a buyer can get introduced and
then you'll be able to find like like
which all features are actually your
predicted rateables that's like a
step-by-step procedure and finding as
productivity builds but yeah you have
there is a like a list of protect
attributes used in general like race or
ethnicity or gender but this is more of
a systematic flow like to go through
each and every bias a possible bias each
and every possible uh like like go
through your data set your columns and
identify like which column can cause
which kind of bias understand your data
set that's some
Morena is asking could you elaborate a
bit more on how AUC can measure fairness
in an ml model
okay so basically uh I I hope she's
mentioning about the ROC like the curve
so basically you will have a curve uh
it's a curve that will actually depict
the performance uh Matrix performance of
a classification model in all possible
scenarios so it'll give us the area
under the curve so we can see that like
if the area under the curve uh like
there are like certain values for I'm
not I'm not actually remembering the
values but yeah there are certain values
for which your EUC is considered to be
good there are certain set thresholds so
I I also told that like these metals
have set thresholds accepted values you
can see that if your a area under the
ROC curve is falling to your particular
set threshold then it is actually
considered to be fair as it's not and
okay as I told it's like a kind of a
hyper parameter that needs to be tuned
according to your use case so that's
nice we can't actually generalize
everything generalize everything but
yeah tune your hyper parameter according
to your use case but there are like
certain set value use for each and every
uh like each of these fairness matrices
you can you can feel free to use them
but yes understand your data set see if
that's applicable for you like
understand everything and then yeah use
them
the next question is what do we Thrive
to achieve in the case of fairness being
the representation of our world or
creating a model that will influence our
world in a positive way
what do we Thrive to achieve in the case
of fairness being the representation of
our world or creating a model that will
influence or a world in a positive way
okay yeah by fairness what I mean is
like what fairness generally means is
like absence of bias it's not like
converting the world into a positive way
like in all the scenario as I told a
bias can get introduced it's not like
making the world more fair like making
the more world like the making the world
more positive or something it is like uh
you know like we'll have bias like in
most of the real world scenario we can't
get an ideal scenario or something we
will have like a by We There are chances
that a bias can get introduced the focus
of fairness is to like eliminate the
bias or reduce the bias as much as we
can like at least we can make the model
perform better it's it's uh yeah we are
not trying to make an ideal scenario we
are trying to like make us our side a
little more better better like our model
perform a little more better
the last question is can we optimize for
fairness at the moment of training
can we optimize for fairness at the
moment of training
yeah like some of these we can
understand from uh the so as I told like
in every stage we can actually find out
and like start our optimization for
fairness so in training stage before
training stage itself like we can
understand the data set right we can see
the data distribution so we can
eliminate like uh data distribution if
there is some particular subgroup is
underrepresented we can actually do over
sampling or we can do under sampling or
we can create synthetic data set we can
do some kind of these things even before
like we go to production so in the model
training phase also like when if the
model actually comes with uh like a
better data set to train the model that
is actually ideal we need not wait till
the production phase we can actually do
this before our training phase itself
making our training data set a little
more uh balanced so that is what we can
do before the production phase
thank you for the great insight into
ethics in ml thank you
[Applause]